let's dig a little deeper into the
battle over the children with multiple
outlets claiming verbal abuse Brad
lunging and striking and being out of
control what are investigators looking
for one of the hardest things for an
investigator to determine is what is
abuse when has that person crossed the
line is a quick slap on the tuition is
screaming and yelling abuse over time
courts have widely expanded the concept
of abuse it could be multiple emails it
could be yelling and screaming it could
be throwing things it could be just mere
threats it could be the way you look at
somebody we can confirm that brad is not
seeing Maddox pax Zahara Shiloh knox and
vivienne all six could be key witnesses
in this case the investigators not going
to ask the children question like was
your father drunk is this the first time
your father's yelled at you the
investigators are going to ask more
generic questions because they don't
want to implant bad memories into these
children's minds